los líderes europeos siguen aquí
reunidos en Bruselas dispuestos a llegar
a un acuerdo para bajar los precios de
la energía ahora mismo están muy
divididos los países porque tienen
varias cuestiones por encima de la mesa
en que una de las más divisidas es el
límite al precio del gas la comisión
europea ha propuesto un límite flexible
a todas las compras de gas que se hacen
en el Continente Pero por otra parte
algunos países como por ejemplo España
Francia o Italia pueden ir más allá y
piden un límite al precio del gas que
genera electricidad algo que no gusta
países como Alemania o Países Bajos
porque creen que esto habría aumentar el
consumo y por otra parte creen que
países exportadores como Noruega
decidirían entonces en vender sugas a
otros mercados como el asiático donde no
hay ningún límite donde parece que sí
hay más consenso en la reunión de hoy es
la de aprobar una plataforma de compras
conjuntas de gas y así reducir los
precios tal y como se hizo por ejemplo
con la compra de vacunas durante la
pandemia de 19 Eso sí es una medida más
pensada para el año que viene pero lo
que quieren ahora los consumidores y
muchos gobiernos lo que piden es que se
necesitan medidas ahora para reducir la
factura de la electricidad y la factura
del gas Así que se pruebe aquí una
reunión muy larga en Bruselas